[Music]
thank you
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
program I'd like to know this is a
question and answer program where we
give those who watch our program uh the
chance of asking questions uh based on
the Bible that perhaps they can't find
an answer to and we do the research and
we do everything possible to find the
answer to the question for those who
send them to us I just want to give you
the address where you can send your
questions and we will do everything
possible to answer those questions it'll
be on the screen TV at some
tv.org once again TV at some
tv.org
we will do our utmost if there is an
answer to try and find the answer for
you I have with me Pastor Daniel Miranda
who is associate speaker here at Secrets
unsealed and also coordinates our
Spanish-speaking work his wife does
social media for our Spanish-speaking
work here at the ministry we're glad to
have him very level-headed when it comes
to theology which is why we like to have
here at Secrets unsealed we're very glad
that you're here
thank you Pastor board it's a it's a
privilege for me to be here learning
from the voice of experience well praise
the Lord
okay we have several very good questions
today but before we get into the
questions we want to do what we always
do before we open the word and that is
to ask the Lord to be with us so if you
could please pray for us that the Lord
will bless the program amen let's pray
Heavenly Father we come before you again
and we want to ask you for your guidance
and your help in answering these
questions
you know that your children have sent
them because they sincerely want to do
your will and and know your Bible so I
prayed Lord that you may Enlighten our
minds on the minds of those who are
watching us in the name of Jesus amen
amen
okay what question do we have first
today
so this question comes from Jonas apatu
and the question reads why do we have to
die
our bodies will get rotten and then to
be resurrected again
so his question is why why to die and
then
our bodies will be will get rotten and
then we'll resurrect again I think the
answer is found in the three-letter word
s-i-n sin exactly yeah that was exactly
what I was going to say but we have to
go back to Genesis chapter 3 to find out
why death comes into the world yeah
Genesis chapter
3 actually even chapter 2 when God yeah
gives the command not to eat from The
Forbidden tree and he also gives 17. yes
Genesis 2 15 through 17. then the Lord
God took the man and put him in the
Garden of Eden to tend and to keep it
and the Lord God commanded the man
saying of every tree of the garden you
may freely eat
but of the tree of the knowledge of Good
and Evil you shall not eat
for in the day that you eat of it you
shall surely die so we were not created
to die but sin entered into the world
and then death came as a result and then
our bodies die
we rotten that's true but then the
resurrection is the most amazing thing
because God makes all things new with a
glorified body and we can live again and
be with Jesus if we have been faithful
for eternity
yeah in fact in Genesis chapter 3
and verse 19 God pronounced the sentence
upon Adam and the entire human race when
he said in the sweat of your face you
shall eat bread till you return to the
ground because he was brought forth from
the ground
for da for all of you were taken out of
it you were taken for dust you are
and to dust you shall return yes so Adam
was made of dust and because of sin he
returned to the dust but the good news
is that when Jesus comes he's going to
recreate Adam and all those who are in
Christ and then we will have a body uh
Incorruptible and immortal like it was
before sin at the very beginning amen
maybe we could go to First Corinthians
15 and I know this is not mentioned in
the question but just to add and clarify
more what our brother here is asking
is it really a big deal or is it really
difficult for God to resurrect us even
though our bodies are eaten and rotten
that's not a problem for God
someone verse 35 says but someone will
say
how are the dead raised up
and with what body do they come verse 36
foolish one what you saw is not made
alive unless it dies and what you saw
you do not saw that body that shall be
but mere grain perhaps wheat or some
other grain but God gives it a body as
he pleases and to each seed its own body
so what is the illustration here what
you put into into the ground is not the
same thing that comes up right it's a
different body the same thing what goes
into the grave is not the same thing
that comes up and then the point here is
verse 42 and 44 through 44.
so also is the resurrection of the Dead
the body is sown in corruption
it is raised in incorruption it is sown
in dishonor it is raised in glory
it is sown in weakness it is raised in
power
it is sown a natural body it is raised a
spiritual body there is a natural body
and there is a spiritual body
okay so basically
between these two points of time is sin
yes you know in a world of sin things
corrupt things get old things get
wrinkled
because of sin but when everything is
restored there will no longer be any of
that it will be like God originally
planned if man should not sin amen
okay so I hope that that answer is uh
satisfactory uh we have another question
that you know we have answered in a
previous program this question is asked
by Kathy Cook
and the question is this as God is
all-knowing
would it have been possible to just not
create Satan will you please answer this
question would it been possible because
God God says well you know I know that
if I create Lucifer Lucifer is going to
sin so I better not create him I better
save myself the mess could God think
that way no
why not well that would be very that
would be a selfish thought from God
um if that were if they were the case
then most of us should have never been
born because we're going to sin and
we're going to create or give him a big
problem
it will be the only solution whenever
this question comes up I usually answer
the only solution
for God to never for for sin to never
enter the universe is for the godhead to
stay by themselves without creating any
being
because then he is the only one that is
perfect and the only one that will never
have the possibility of sinning but the
fact that we are created and have free
will we will always have the possibility
of falling and that was the case in
heaven and unfortunately that happened
with Lucifer but God gave him the chance
as he gave the chance to every Heavenly
being
yeah you know the Bible makes it clear
that even in heaven
the beings had freedom of choice yes
because uh Satan not only did Satan
choose to go against God but he took a
third of the angels that chose to follow
him so God guarantees freedom of choice
we notice also in the Book of Genesis
that God respects Freedom of Choice he
placed a tree in the garden
and he said you know you can eat from
all the trees of the garden that's good
but if you eat from the Tree of
knowledge of Good and Evil that's evil
so that could the tree of knowledge of
Good and Evil proves that God gave Adam
and Eve Freedom of Choice amen as he
gives us freedom of choice now what
would we think of a God who created
beings with no freedom of choice
there's no capacity to love without
freedom of choice because you choose
whom you're going to love yes so let's
suppose that God
thought to himself
not anybody else but he's thinking to
himself you know
I know that if I create Lucifer
and Lucifer is going to choose
evil
and it's going to cause all of this mess
in the universe
you know
I'll just choose not to create him
nobody will know that I chose not to
create him but me God would be going
against his principles yes because he
would be creating beings only who could
say yes and not know
so God
it God respected so much freedom of
choice
that he was willing
to have Lucifer sin and create this mess
and Adam and Eve sinned and make the
mess even more complicated because he
respects fully and completely freedom of
choice and usually we think of this from
the perspective of of us so you know God
created Lucifer and he created him and
even he knew all of this mess you know
all the crime and all the drugs and all
these things didn't God care about us
but we don't think about how much sin
costs God
he saw he suffered much more than us yes
because of sin so uh why didn't God just
say you know I know that it's going to
be painful for me so I'm not going to
create it I mean Eve I'm not going to
create Satan because Lucifer because if
I do you know it's going to cause
suffering for me no he didn't spare
himself the suffering exactly he's still
created Adam and Eve and he created
Lucifer knowing the pain that it was
going to cost him not only us yes amen
very good
all right what is the next question
so the next question let me see here
okay comes from well we don't find the
name here Lily I think stargazer lily
stargazer lily yes
hello thank you very much for the
wonderful blessing of the Matthew 24
study series
I had a question in regards to the
references for the following statement
and then she quotes the Eye of
Providence is a Masonic symbol
representing Lucifer the great architect
of the universe
and then she's quoting from lesson
number six page 72 in your study guides
when I try to look into this on the web
all I find are claims that this
represented the All-Seeing Eye of God's
Providence not Lucifer many history
sources seem to State thinking it
represented Lucifer in a conspiracy
belief
may I have reference support for it
representing Lucifer
okay that's a good question the only
documentation that I have
is that in the city of Haverstraw New
York many years ago I was invited to
give a series of meetings
and that series of meeting was held in a
masonic temple
and it was amazing to really speak and
there was kind of eerie because they had
all kind of all kind of wood art where
they had you know different beasts and
dragons and all different kinds of uh
occultic symbols and interestingly
enough I saw there in the Masonic
Masonic temple the same Insignia that is
found on the one dollar bill uh the the
pyramid that is not uh you know complete
with uh with a Sunburst above it and it
was in the Masonic temple and
um
so from there I concluded that that is
not really a Christian symbol
but it's a Masonic symbol and by the way
practically all of those that devise
this Great Seal of the United States
were Masons you know the founding
fathers of the United States were
Freemasons and uh President Roosevelt
was a Freemason and uh and you know he's
the he's the one who decided to place uh
the Great Seal on the on the one dollar
bill so uh it's based on my observation
that I brought that forth in the Matthew
chapter 24 series
um not from any documentation that I
found on Google okay Okay interesting
all right uh we have uh the next
question is actually a collection of
five questions
and they are sent to us by
hmm who is that guy obviously a
pseudonym so anyway uh here's question
number one I have studied that our
bodies are the Temple of the Holy Spirit
First Corinthians 3 16. that there is a
temple of God in heaven as well
that we are the bride of Christ Faithful
Servants of the Lord the Sheep of God
Our Shepherd and children of God
but how do I fathom these terms which
apply to God's people
so how do we apply the idea that the
temple of God is God's people and also a
temple literal temple in heaven
well I I don't see I don't know if I
understand the question very well
because then he says how do I fathom
these terms I'm not sure if he's
referring to
the different terms to God's people
bride of Christ Faithful Servants sheeps
of our God or Shepherd and children of
God
and and the reference to to the Heavenly
Sanctuary but um I think your question
is close to the sense of of the question
that the person is asking
well when we go to the Bible we find
both literal temples and spiritual
temples we find first
um the Mosaic Temple
actually if we even go before we have
the the Eden Temple that was kind of
like a sanctuary we have the temple
built by Moses we find we have the
temple the Tabernacle yes we have uh
Solomon's Temple but actually was built
by Solomon then zeruba Bells which was
later remodeled by Herod okay those are
the literal templates temples when we
come to the New Testament then the
temple acquires more spiritual sense
because now the Earth the Earthly Temple
lost its significance when Jesus left
the temple he says your house is made
until you desolate so we have Jesus
himself a place
the symbology of the temple to himself
his body destroyed his Temple right and
I will raise it up in the third day so
his body was the temple the church is
also described as a temple I believe in
Ephesians chapter 2. and then we
as individuals as described as a temple
so this doesn't contradict the fact that
In Heaven There is a temple which is the
true one so wherever Jesus is that's
literal wherever the holy spirit is
that's a spiritual since the holy spirit
is here on Earth interceding for us so
everything related to
the work of the Holy Spirit must be
understood as spiritual even the temples
but where Jesus is in heaven that is the
literal Temple yeah and um just to refer
to the passage that you mentioned a few
moments ago uh Ephesians chapter 2 which
is speaking about the spiritual Temple
of the church the church exactly it says
now therefore you are no longer
strangers and foreigners but fellow
citizens with the Saints and members of
the household of God
having been built on the foundation of
the Apostles and Prophets see the
foundations our spiritual foundations
their people uh not uh not literal
Stones so it says Bill having been built
on the foundation of the Apostles and
Prophets Jesus Christ himself being the
Chief Cornerstone not a literal
Cornerstone it's a person and then it
says in whom the whole building being
fitted together grows into a holy Temple
in the Lord we are the stones that are
built upon the foundation and the Chief
Cornerstone and then notice verse 22 in
whom you also are being built together
for a Dwelling Place of God in the
spirit
so God wants the Holy Spirit to be in
the church
God wants the Holy Spirit to be in US
and of course the spirit
lives in the Heavenly Temple it's the
glory the Shekinah of God and so there's
no contradiction between a literal
Heavenly Temple the body being the
temple and the church being the temple
there are different ways of teaching the
same truth that the holy spirit's one
Holy Spirit wants to dwell in each one
amen
okay then we have a second question uh
here the Earthly Sanctuary was a pattern
of the sanctuary in heaven
Earthly Sanctuary had animal sacrifices
what was the Heavenly sanctuaries
ultimate sacrifice and was it done in
heaven in other words was the sacrifice
made in heaven no it was not
and the book of Hebrews the author of
Hebrews clearly
points to Jesus's sacrifice and as the
ultimate sacrifice
so the work of on Earth of Jesus Christ
corresponds to the work on the outer
court right okay so we see Jesus's
sacrifice on the altar of sacrifice and
his resurrection on the labor
there is no sacrifice in heaven because
Jesus's sacrifice is enough
yet the book of Hebrews says that he
entered the Heavenly Sanctuary with his
own blood with his own blood but it was
the blood that he shed on Earth in other
words Jesus is not sacrificed in heaven
he's sacrificed on Earth and then he
takes his blood
into the sanctuary in heaven amen
because as you mentioned the court the
work of the Court takes place on Earth
and the work of the Holy place and the
most holy place takes place in the
Heavenly sanctuary and perhaps I read a
text to back up our answer Hebrews
chapter 9 verse 23 therefore
it was necessary that the copies of the
things in the heavens should be purified
with this but the Heavenly things
themselves with better sacrifices than
these
for Christ has not entered the holy
places made with hands which are the
copies of the true but in heaven itself
now to appear in the presence of God for
us not that he should offer himself
often as the high priest enters the most
holy place every year with the blood of
another
he then would have had to suffer often
since the foundation of the world but
now once at the end of the ages he has
appeared to put away sin by the
sacrifice of himself so here is the
answer
so the answer to this particular
question is no he was not sacrificed in
heaven he was sacrificed on Earth but
the efficacy of his blood
is in heaven still where he ministers
with his blood before his father okay
the third question in this series of
questions is the Earthly Sanctuary is
cleansed by a high priest as he
ministered after the atonement because
it was defiled but why is the Heavenly
Sanctuary with no sin cleansed by Christ
who is ministering in the Heavenly
Sanctuary according to Hebrews 8 verse
2. so how can something as holy as the
Heavenly Sanctuary be defiled by the
record of sin is the way that I
understand this question yes well I
perceive there is a misconception in the
question in saying that the sanctuary in
heaven doesn't have sin what about
Daniel A14 tells us something different
yes right because Daniel a 14 which is
referring clearly to the Heavenly
Sanctuary it says that the sanctuary
will be cleansed until 2 300 days so if
it if it will be cleansed it means that
their sins recorded in the heavens
Sanctuary again the typology
as the Earthly Sanctuary recorded the
sins of the people throughout the year
saw the Heavenly Sanctuary records the
sins of us when we confess they are
recorded there in the books of Records
also we need to recognize you know
you know people say how can something as
filing as Sin
be in the presence of a Most Holy Place
how can you have sin which is defiles in
such a Most Holy place in heaven and I
usually answer with uh with another
example and that is was Christ
absolutely perfect and holy amen he was
yes
yet did he take sin upon himself he did
by imputation
in other words the sin in the Heavenly
Sanctuary is imputed to the sanctuary it
is credited to the credited to the
sanctuary but it does not belong to the
sanctuary just like our sins were
credited to Jesus but they do not belong
to Jesus right so if Jesus the most holy
and perfect being in the universe could
bear the record of sin
so then very clearly the record of sin
can be in heaven in a super holy place
because in the case of the sanctuary of
Jesus sin does not belong there it is
alien to there but it is imputed until
uh the individual who is ultimately
responsible for sin Bears the final load
at the end of the day of atonement amen
okay question number four
I believe he is ministering after his
ultimate atonement but what kind of
ministering is what got me thinking is
there another kind of ministering done
by the high priest apart from cleansing
the sanctuary and of course the answer
to that question is yes exactly uh you
know the the high priest also had an
intercessory role yes
something some people have the idea that
Jesus sees his work of intercession
and in 1844
but in 1844 in the in the ministry of
the most holy place he continued the
work that he was doing sure but now an
added function is given right and and is
the function of uh of of the high priest
cleansing the sanctuary uh the function
of judgment he is now judgment he
received judgment from the father to
begin the work of judgment on behalf on
behalf of the Saints or in favor of the
Saints right as Daniel 7 22 says but it
doesn't mean
that he has ceased to intercede we know
that he will cease to intercede when he
leaves the most holy place when
probation closes now his
on a building
say he lives his perfect life
and because he lived a perfect life
he dies for sin he sheds his blood then
he enters into the holy place with his
blood to intercede for us
and then in 1844 he enters into the most
holy Place continues applying his blood
to those who come by faith to him but
adding an additional function which is
the function of judgment but he does not
cease to do the interceding through his
blood and apply his perfect life to
those who come to him so basically in
the most holy place he has a double
function he's the intercessor until
probation closes and on the other hand
he is also the judge amen
okay the final question in this series
of questions is why is the temple or
Heavenly Sanctuary disappearing
in Revelation 21 22. and how does it
disappear with the actual pattern Ten
Commandments inside the Ark of the
Covenant which God God's Throne sits on
so why did he not see in the city a
temple
well
um my answer to that is uh
let me read Revelation 21 22 but I saw
no temple in it for the Lord God
Almighty and the lamb are its Temple
the temple had fulfilled already it's
soteriological function by this point
but the temple which this time the city
will function as the temple in the new
heavens and the new Earth will continue
to play or I would say function more in
doxological way because they will come
to worship once a week and once a month
a month before the city so the temple in
itself with its cathological and
soterological functions will no longer
be in the new heavens and the new Earth
but but the city will have now actually
even the dimensions and all that there
are so many similarities of the city and
the temple
there in that specific time I also
recommend that the person who asked the
question and those who are watching read
the chapter of Ellen White's first
vision
where she very clearly
says that the temple will be out in one
of the hills outside the city of New
Jerusalem in other words that there is
no temple in the city the temple is on a
mountain outside the city and so what uh
what John is saying I saw no temple in
the city he's not saying there wasn't
any Temple so there'll still be the ark
it'll still have the Ten Commandments in
it the Ten Commandments will not have
been nailed to the cross as many people
believe well time has flown by thank you
for joining us we hope to see you next
time on this program I'd like to know
foreign
[Music]